[Music]
you look gorgeous you look beautiful
I look like a girl today those arms your
arms are absolutely incredible you could
beat me to death in a second and I would
enjoy that so much I really would
so much to talk about first of all this
was last month's ESPN Magazine the body
issue you're on the cover
yeah and looking absolutely beautiful
and there are no this is mine I'm such a
creep a lot of photographs of you in
here quite quite nude what's that oh
yeah you put your hand wraps on it I
mean I'm just curious I've had a bunch
of women on the show recently who've
posed nude and then I'm gonna show ask
them about it cuz I'm a perv and then
they say I wasn't really nude I was
wearing underwear a thong and they
airbrush it out and that that's the new
technique these days were you really
naked in this no I was really really
naked and I I didn't I thought there was
so like side but but I thought I guess
they thought it was a good thing to show
a little bit of extra so yeah and so you
did that were you self-conscious at all
or being an athlete you think it you
know you I used to be really
self-conscious but this is like a way
for me to really overcome that you know
and I got over once I was naked you know
the mystery was gone I wasn't gonna get
even more naked so once you're naked
there is no more more naked well let's
talk about there's a lot of people out
there who probably don't know mixed
martial arts how you know what the rules
are when you're fighting and mixed
martial arts there are actually things
you're not allowed to do sometimes if
you're watching it you feel like both
opponents can really much try anything
but that's not the case no you can't
like there's no like a gouging you can't
like tickle the other person there's no
you can't actually definitely ticklish
but if you can't open him and slap them
which I thought it would be often just
to walk out there and slap a girl but
apparently the only reason why you can't
because you might poke them in the eye
okay so there's no eye gouging there's
no there's no slapping no tickling no
tickling is that something you have to
toe like boxers is
like heavyweight boxers no tackling it
no they don't because I don't fly on the
ground so much so you don't have can't
put them down and you're like I got you
you know that never really happened you
really couldn't pin someone's both arms
down like you did it like you know your
little brother or sister yeah I get an
MMA if you want so that they had to rule
that out they've ruled that out so
people were trying it that's what I love
is people work okay now you have claimed
in interviews that you do not feel pain
the way you think a lot of people do is
that true I just come to think of it
like objectively like I don't know it's
come on and I feel pain it's just
information go into my brain and it's
not me it's happening to know I can
choose to acknowledge that information
or not and you know God really so
because I can't do that when I feel pain
it goes right to my brain and then
that's just it I'm crying I'm shrieking
and this is like a hangnail you know it
doesn't take much well we don't know
know this place there's plenty of pain
in this job you you have a deviated
septum and you think that this helps you
when you're fighting why Oh cuz if I get
punched in the nose it just squishes on
down says is it goes right down yeah I
get hit all day and it's just I also
looks like one of those inflatable clown
things it just comes down to fighting I
got it like I was driving like back of
my graveyard shift trying to I want to
get started fighting I just fell asleep
with a wheel in bong and now I don't
have to worry about it how convenient
you were like thanks car accident